- What we've done at Bard is
build an institution which sets,
really the tone
and sets the standard
for the return of real
educational opportunity
and real hope
and real meaning
in our prison systems
across the United States.
And the students that
you've seen in these videos,
it's so important to remember,
are not analogous to
or not in some way like,
but they are exactly the same people
who our last generation
of most distinguished
social scientists and
leaders in government
and in education,
described as super predators, right?
Who we built a giant
multi-billion apparatus
to keep away from us.
The cynicism that was involved in that
was not limited to some
imaginary terrible people.
We were all culpable in it
and the kind of cynicism
that led to those decisions,
I think were not limited
to law enforcement.
They also included the great leaders
of the most important secular, liberal
institutions in American life.
And those are our
colleges and universities.
So at Bard, our idea is how do we
refashion, how do we smash the way
we've done college admission
in the United States
and engage as many kinds of Americans
as we possibly can in the most ambitious,
most rigorous, most dignified kind
of education we possible could.
At our last BA graduation two years ago,
at Eastern Correctional Facility,
a full half of those graduates,
incarcerated men of all ages,
a full half of them were
majors in mathematics.
How far does that go to puncture
the liberal prejudice
that you find in every part of life
of who's interested in what
and who's capable of what.